hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar unveil the inflammatory response
with novel essays for protein and gene
expression I am Megan Pascal of lab
roots and I'll be your moderator for
today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and brought to you
by Thermo Fisher Scientific
to learn more visit thermofisher.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click Send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
I'd like to now welcome our speaker
sigran padernia PhD manager product
development Life Sciences of Thermo
Fisher Scientific Seagram you may now
begin your presentation
so thank you for the introduction and
welcome again to this webinar which will
provide important insights into novel
highly multiplexed protein and gene
expression assays to study the
inflammatory response and to support
your research
as you well know inflammation is a
crucial part and host defense mechanism
of the immune system protecting from
infection or injury and the figure on
the left highlights the complexity of
the immune Network that involves a
variety of different cells and molecules
including cytokines chemokines and other
soluble factors that are all critical
players in shaping local and systemic
immune responses
however inappropriate regulation
resulting in an imbalance between
stimulatory and inhibitory mediators can
be associated with various pathological
conditions ranging from inherited
monogenic disorders such as the primary
hemophobicide
lymphocystocytosis as Illustrated on the
right a rare genetic defect which
impairs the cytotoxic function of
certain immune cells while a
hyperinflammatory condition with
overactive immune cells and excessive
release of inflammatory soluble factors
is summarized below might also occur as
a side effect of therapies including
Cartesian therapy or as a complication
of infections such as induced by SARS
cov2
so inflammatory Related Disorders and
the triggers can be quite heterogeneous
and and consequently there is great
interest in uncovering the cellular
cross talk and the complex but
coordinated interplay between all these
factors to better understand the
mechanisms underlying various
inflammatory conditions and disease
Estates
in this context RNA and protein
biomarkers can be effective indicators
of these processes and therefore the
efficient and accurate quantification by
appropriate High throughput tools very
useful to explore and study all facets
of the immune system
in vitrogen quantity implex and
procortiplex assays make use of the
established Multiplex technology on the
luminex instrument platform enabling a
unique multi-ohmics approach by
providing a high throughput solution for
the measurement of both RNA and protein
expression levels on one instrument to
support immune monitoring cytokine
profiling and to accelerate the
discovery and verification of biomarkers
and targets across key research areas
so notably both applications allow for
accurate and simultaneous measurement of
up to 80 Targets in each well of a 96 or
384 well played from a variety of sample
types from different species with just
simple requirements so for sample
preparation
so these essays which are on the one
hand hybridization based quantity implex
assays for RNA quantitation from a
single lysate or even from complex
tissue samples and on the other hand
precautoplex immunoassays for protein
quantitation from serum plasma cell
culture supernatants and many other
biofluids are reliable scalable and
highly customizable tools for high
throughput protein and gene expression
studies
so as mentioned both essays make use of
the xmap multi-analyte profiling
technology which basically relies on
proprietary magnetic microspheres that
are color coded with the combinations of
red and infrared fluorophores resulting
in unique and spectrally distinct bead
sets or beat regions as illustrated by
the schematic and that can be classified
by any luminex instrument
and as outlined here a procortiplex
essays enable protein Target detection
via highly specific antibody pair
binding similar to a traditional Elisa
by utilizing this color-coded and
antibody conjugated magnetic capture
beads to specifically bind an antigen as
well as a pirating conjugated antibody
mediated detector using a strep dividend
FICO Eritrean as a fluorescent reporter
molecule which is compatible with all
luminix instruments
with regards to Signal detection the
Optics uh in the compact analyzers
excite the internal Betis to identify
each of these microspheres as well as
any reporter or detection die captured
which allows for the quantification of
individual analytes found on each
microsphere
the workflow or as shown on the right
further illustrates a step-by-step how
it works so each bit set is assigned to
a different Target analyte and coated
with a Target specific antibody and this
differentially diet capture bead sets
are mixed and added to a sample for a
two-hour incubation allowing the analyte
and specific capture of multiple targets
from a single sample in parallel and
following a wash step the captured
protein biomarkers are incubated with a
mix of biotinylated and analyzed
specific detection antibodies to form an
immunocomplex and after another wash and
incubation with the streptavidine FICO
Eritrean to and removal of excess
fluorescent reporter molecule the sample
is finally ready for readout and
Analysis on one of the luminex
instruments
taking a look at the quantity implex
essays that combine both the xmap
feed-based multi-analyte profiling
technology and Branch DNA technology for
Target hybridization and the direct
measurement of RNA transcripts via
signal amplification rather than Target
amplification and as Illustrated here
the elisa-like workflow is a
straightforward four-step process
starting with the preparation and
Analysis of samples so to release and
stabilize RNA from cultured cells whole
blood virus bacteria to more complex
tissue samples from plant or animal
origin followed by a Target
hybridization step upon overnight
incubation with a Target specific probe
sets on luminex capture beats that are
comprised of a specific capture
extenders label extenders and blocking
probes
finally in the third step sequential
hybridization of pre-amplifier amplifier
and biotinylated label probes uh build
the signal amplification tree and using
a streptivity in FICO Eritrean as a
fluorescent reporter molecule the signal
can be finally detected on one of other
luminex instruments that is used for
readout and Analysis
the value of pairing these two
applications provided on one instrument
is further highlighted by a study a
previous sales published in methods so
we're complementing procontoplex
immunothy essays with quantity analysis
to measure both proteins and RNA levels
from the same sample provides a more
comprehensive data set which can help to
find the interrelation particularly in
complex biological processes or disease
models so to examine if protein levels
reflect the corresponding gene
expression levels within a single sample
run on a luminix system
isolated cells have been stimulated with
LPS for up to 72 hours and the
supinations profiled for protein levels
on a procontoplex 65 Plex panel and a
satellite that's used for measuring RNA
levels on a matching cute bondagine Plex
panel on the luminix system
on the right the results Illustrated for
total
protein quantitation indicated by the
bar graphs and the normalized gene
expression analysis indicated by the
line graphs for six different Target
analytes that demonstrates similar
Trends with corresponding gene
expression levels and protein
translation for il-1 beta tnf Alpha il-6
and mid-1 beta in figure a while figure
B below shows also some examples of
inconsistent Trends with non-matching
changes in RNA and protein levels for
il-16 and Trail pointing out that mRNA
expression may not always translate to
the protein level and so the measurement
of our mRNA or protein expression levels
alone may not tell the complete story
overall this example demonstrates that
the single sample can indeed provide
both gene expression and protein
profiles which enables a more
comprehensive exploratory experiments
and providing a more holistic view on a
particular research topic
another published example demonstrating
the combined use of quantity implex and
precautoplex assays is a research study
on SI rna-based identification of
targets Associated to inflammatory bowel
disease in a monocyte derived tendritic
cell models here quantity implex and
precautoplex Multiplex assays have been
used to measure Gene and protein
expression levels of anti-inflammatory
r10 and pro-inflammatory P40 levels
amongst other targets primary testing
using a specific IBD Library identified
sirna pools that preferably reduce the
P40 secretion and increase the album The
L10 secretion and or alt MP40 ratio
and in-depth analysis finally led to the
selection of 10 IBD related targets that
are further verified as potential
anti-inflammatory drugs in this case
so taking a closer look at the quantity
Simplex assays that are also available
in the 384 World format enabling even
higher throughput Multiplex gene
expression analysis and allowing for
more efficient compounds testing to
accelerate biomerica and Drug Discovery
studies
here is a detailed overview of the
complete workflow for 384 well essays
including information on the Hands-On
and incubation times 4d1 and day 2 of
the protocol so while the Hands-On time
of one hour on day one and of less than
one hour on day two is fairly minimal
there are still various steps in the
workflow particularly on day two that
require the transfer of samples or
washes between the three times one hour
incubation which can be considerably
simplified by integration of automated
equipment so Automation and batch
processing options are readily available
for this essay format to further
decrease Hands-On time while increasing
the sample throughput
so with higher throughput and an
increasing number of data points
software solutions for streamlined
analysis are getting more and more
important and there are two software
Solutions available to support quantity
implex data analysis on the one hand the
quantity implex data analysis app which
is free software available through the
through connect at the thermofish
scientific cloud-based platform with an
easy to follow workflow that provides
also customization capabilities for
normalization and Analysis of gene
expression data the data collected from
quantity implex assets can be further
most exported into the transcriptome
analysis console software for even more
advanced data processing and graphical
analysis including heat Maps volcano
plots or pathway analysis
on the following slides I'd like to
share a few published examples of how
quantity Simplex assets have been used
for high throughput analysis in
different researcher fields
so in this first example a quantity in
higher throughput essay has been used
for biomarker studies in ipc-derived
retinal pigment cells in this case the
research group started out by
establishing and thoroughly validating a
quantity Simplex assay in the 96 well
format before scaling up to run it in a
384 well format to increase the
throughput and and also decrease the
required sample input they found a
significant correlation of Multiplex
um gene expression data from a quantity
implex assay with a standard qpcr
measurements as shown here in the
correlation plots for the 384 well
format and concluded that this High
throughput essay provides the basis for
the compound testing studies and for
further exploring future treatments for
several retinal degenerative diseases
the value of Multiplex analysis using
High throughput quantity implexes has
been further confirmed by another
research study as shown here on cytokine
driven goblet cell metoplasia in the
lung which is a Hallmark of chronic lung
disease and legs um treatment options so
using a high throughput quantity implex
384 well as say for a com for a compound
Library analysis in 3D bronze Hood
spheres the research group was able to
test almost 5 000 compounds and
identified that Notch 2 is required for
a goblet cell metaplasia in the lung
more specifically They concluded that
the inhibition of Notch 2 prevents
goblet cell metaplasia induced by a
broad range of stimuli and are now
following up to explore potential future
therapeutic avenues for this condition
in Airway diseases
foreign
example the quantity implex 384 will
high throughput as say has been used in
a research study to measure specific
Gene expression-based signatures in
order to identify functionally similar
proteins in this context the assessment
of the technical reproducibility using a
housekeeping Target furthermore revealed
a high level of correlation between
replicates concluding that the quantity
implex platform has distinct advantages
and disabled methods for high throughput
gene expression analysis
so switching or turning now to
precautoplex essays for highly
multiplexed protein expression studies
the portfolio of procortiplex panels had
just been further expanded now offering
the new immune immune response panel
which is currently the largest Multiplex
protein assay available on the luminix
x-map bar based system that enables the
simultaneous measurement of 80 key
soluble factors in a single well to
study the immune function and providing
a more complete picture of the immune
response Network
performance evaluation of this immune
response procontoplex panel in untreated
human serum samples and pre-treated
plasma samples reveal the differential
expression pattern of these 80 targets
as Illustrated in the bar chart
and moreover side by side comparison of
sample concentrations are detected in
human serum and stimulated plasma
samples between a small Plex in this
case a nine-flex chemokime procortiplex
panel and the human immune response 80
Plex panel as shown here for a selected
representative analytes of human mcp4
and ccl1 demonstrate consistency in both
large and small scale Multiplex panels
enabling high content analysis without
compromising DSA performance
further regression analysis that have
been performed on comparing the small
nine-plex and the 80 Plex panels reveals
a high correlation between large and
small scale Multiplex assays within our
Square value or greater than 0.9 for
both selected targets as Illustrated
here which makes it easy to switch
between small Plex and high Flex panels
while ensuring reliable and reproducible
results
besides the performance comparison
between the human 65 Plex and the 80
Plex panel in human plasma samples
furthermore demonstrate also highly
correlating sample values as shown here
for human MDC as representative Target
that underscores the consistency also
across a high Plex panels
so how a high throughput Multiplex
protein assets used to support research
and pre-clinical studies on the
following slides I'd like to also share
a few published examples of how
precautoplex Multiplex panels have been
used for immune monitoring across
different research Fields including
Source copy2 research as shown here in
the first example on the left in a
publication in nature where the th1
teach to cytokine 11 Plex most
precautoplex panel has been used in the
pre-clinical development of two vaccine
candidates by biontec farza to analyze
the T cell mediated antigen responses in
mice following vaccination
as well as in a second example as shown
on the right where the human immune
monitoring 65 takes per quarterflex
panel has been used in a cross-sectional
exploratory study to determine specific
cytokine profiles in peripheral human
blood during the early onset of covid-19
infection to ultimately help identify
and develop Innovative treatment
strategies against starskovic infection
panels have also a hyplex panels in
particular have also been widely used
for immune monitoring in the cancer
cancer research space such such as shown
here where in total 59 chemokines
cytokines growth factors and soluble
immunocology checkpoint molecules have
been measured in plasma samples
collected from individuals with
metastatic diseases to determine the
response to immunotherapy following a
discovery and verification phase finally
a two-cytokine signature composed of
rantus and pdl1 that's shown in the
Scatter Plots below was found to be
associated with increased Disease
Control rate and the survival which
underscores the predictive value of
these targets for the stratification of
individuals who may benefit from a
certain treatment
moreover as shown on the right that the
human immune monitoring 65 Plex server
quarterplex panel has also been used to
identify serum cytokine signatures to
help stratify individuals with systemic
sclerosis and to differentiate between
high and low risk groups as well as to
identify statistics cytokine expression
profiles from Human serum and exosome
samples as summarized on the left are
dependent on different isolation methods
and to further evaluate exosomes as
potential blood-based biomarkers for
metastatic processes and more advanced
tumor stages
so all together these examples underline
the value of procautoplex Multiplex
assays it's efficient High throughput
tools for immune response profiling in a
wide variety of sample types from
different species and across different
research fields
to accelerate protein profiling and
research even further procontoplex 384
well assays enable Multiplex protein
analysis also in a high throughput
format with optimized reagent
formulation that has been specifically
developed for smaller reaction volumes
in the 384 well flat bottom plates that
require less sample input compared to a
96 well format however without
compromising the sensitivity and
performance of the essays
as shown here uh protoplex 384 will
assays are available in two different
formats um one on the one hand uh um as
a liquid formulation of pre-mixed bead
sets that are provided in a single while
for an extensive selection of analytes
from a variety of different species as
well as as well as an exclusive
ready-to-use format uh with uh plates uh
um and predispensed lyophilized pizza
for workflow convenience
taking a closer look at the workflows
for procato Plex 384 well assays with a
liquid versus live flies the pizza so as
compared to the liquid beads option that
provides premixed speed sets that are to
be pipeted on 384 well flat bottom
plates um the 384 will assess with liar
flies the beets come with a predispensed
capture beats uh lifelized on 384 well
flat bottom plates which eliminates the
beat dispensation step in the general
workflow as outlined here thereby
minimizing a bit dispensation errors and
also reduces the Hands-On time which
makes the workflow even more convenient
comparison between the 96 well and 384
well liquid and lyophyllis beat formats
as shown here revealed a similar
performance of a standard curves from
the same standard mixed slot in
different product formats as Illustrated
here for three selected analytes
ensuring consistent results regardless
of the precautoplex essay format
furthermore When comparing sample values
between the 96 well and 384 well liquid
and lifeless formats are for selected
analytes
furthermore High correlation of sample
concentrations across the precautoplex
formats demonstrate reliable and
reproducible results
this is further confirmed by regression
analysis obtained from Human plasma
samples between the 96 well and the 384
well liquid format which furthermore
shows excellent sample correlations
within our Square greater than 0.9 for
this representative analytes uh making
it easy to switch between 96 well and
384 well formats ensuring consistent
results
and finally High sample correlation
could also be observed between the two
brocato blocks 384 well formats are that
clearly demonstrate equal performance of
essays with lyophilized and liquid beat
formulation as Illustrated here for the
three selected analytes on on this slide
importantly to enhance also data
analysis a free cloud-based software
solution is available on the term
official scientific connect platform so
with the invitation Pro quadruplex
analysis app which enables analysis of
procautoplex multiplexer data required
on luminex and bioplexa instruments from
both 96 well and 384 well formats
featuring 4pl and 5pl curve fit
optimization group wise statistical and
hip map analysis as well as the export
of detailed reports including also
publication quality images and data
so to conclude the in vitrogen
procautoplex and quantity implex
Multiplex assays offer a unique High
throughput solution with the highest
flexibility to measure both Gene and
protein expression levels without
changing the instrument platform to
uncover the immune response Network in
all aspects and besides pre-configured
ready to use panels the new custom panel
configurator tools available on the
website full procautoplex and quantity
implex assays helper to design your own
panels up to a maximum size of an 80
Plex and to mix and match combinations
of available targets appropriate to your
research needs notably the 384 well
format combined with the capabilities of
the the luminex intelliflex or flexmap
3D Systems enable even higher throughput
applications and allow to simultaneously
interrogate large sets of RNA or protein
targets with smaller sample input
however while maintaining consistent
performance as compared to the 96 well
formats and that's shown by comparison
data
to further um shorten your path from
sample to Discovery and accelerate your
research you can take advantages of
custom services that are provided for
all uh the essay platforms by
Outsourcing your essay development
validation or sample testing
so with that I would like to thank you
all for your time and interest in this
presentation and I'm ready to take any
questions now
thank you secret for your informative
presentation if you have a question
you'd like to ask please do so now just
click on the ask a question box and
click Send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for today
let's get started our first question is
can I trust the results obtained from a
huge Multiplex panel like the 80 Plex
so thank you for the question
um yes indeed so the the scale ability
with reproducible performance has been
extensively evaluated and and
demonstrated by comparison data of a
small Plex panel versus the atyplex
procautoplex panel um in as well as
between also High Plex panels as shown
for selected targets of the 65 Plex
human immune monitoring panel compared
to the 80 Plex immune response
precautoplex panel in the presentation
so really confirming that you get the
consistent results with any with any
Plex size
all right thank you our next question is
when would you recommend the use of
Multiplex assays and when would you use
Elisa
so um as mentioned
um Multiplex isas are are really ideal
research tools that can efficiently
support biomarker or drug Discovery
studies so for analysis of larger
compound libraries for cytokine
profiling immune monitoring and many
other applications so basically whenever
whenever high throughput or more
comprehensive analysis of a broader set
of targets is is needed while the Allies
are still the the gold standard of
immunoassays and there are powerful
tools for for single analyte detection
and and for a verification and notably a
particular benefit when when choosing
the different formats and and platforms
um such as high Plex or small Plex or
single analyte assays from from the same
providers or from term official
scientific is whenever technically
feasible the same antibody pairs are
used for development of assays for one
analyte which makes switching between
the formats and the platforms easy while
maintaining also consistency of results
so allowing to really choose the
appropriate tool for for your research
research needs and and for answering a
particular research question
thank you our next question here is what
do I need to run a pro cardaplex or
quantity Gene assay
so you basically you get everything you
need to run a precautoplex essay or
quantity Simplex essay directly from
term official scientific and as a
luminex partner this also covers um the
entire
um range of portfolio of instruments for
multiplexing readouts including also the
intelliflex which is the most recent and
advanced addition to the x-map line of
luminix instruments that is also
available in in a configuration
um with a dual report
detection system and and capabilities
allowing for the simultaneous
measurement of two parameters per beat
region so from the from the same beat
um via an additional Violet reporter
laser and and detection system
great and it looks like we have one more
question here are 384 wow assays with
localized beads available for all PPX
panels
so
um currently available
um catalog products or panels
precautoplex panels in the 384 well
format with with the live LS beta option
uh include the human immune monitoring
65x procontoplex panel the cytokine
chemokine and growth factor 45 human
procautoplex panel as well as the immune
monitoring a 48 Plex miles per car the
Plex panel however you can build your
own
um brocato plexa 3804 well panel as
mentioned in the mix and match style
using also the panel configurator tool
and and select the
lifeless the beat or life Less on plate
option for the respective beat
formulation
great it looks like that brings us to
the end of our q a session today thank
you so much Seagram do you have any
final comments for our audience today
thank you so much
um for your interest in in this
presentation and um hope to see you the
next time
thank you
yes thank you again secret for your time
today and your important research we
would also like to thank lab roots and
our sponsor Thermo Fisher Scientific for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go I'd like to thank our
audience for joining us today and
they're interesting questions
we did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
labyrinths will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with colleagues that may have missed
today's live event until next time
goodbye
bye